it's great to welcome to the program
today David Sinclair who's a professor
of genetics at Harvard Medical School as
well as the author of the new book
lifespan why we age and why we don't
have to David so great to have you on
today
hey thanks David thanks for having me on
so we've interviewed folks like Aubrey
de Grey and others and everybody seems
to apply sort of different language and
vocabulary sometimes to talking about
dealing with aging there's the idea of
curing aging there's the idea of
eliminating aging or making aging
obsolete as an example can you talk a
little bit about sort of your general
philosophy when it comes to the human
lifespan and the sort of way you talk
about and think about it sure well I'm
not anymore to list I'm a realist I'm a
scientist at Harvard Medical School
Brown Durden research we've been doing
for over 25 years now my view though is
that by tackling the major cause of all
diseases in our society all major
diseases which is aging I will have a
dramatic impact on those diseases and
people's longevity and how young they
can stay into the last 5 10 15 years of
their lives and how much of the focus in
your mind needs to be on or I guess when
we think about the approach that you
take is the idea to think about aging as
a condition that we are looking to treat
differently or is it more like for
example when we talk about cancer
treatment we're really talking about a
number of different conditions each each
which needs or requires sort of a
different approach depending on the
particulars the particulars being not
just the particulars of the condition
but also the particulars of the
individual that we're looking to treat
well about ten years ago the field that
I'm in longevity research we declared
that we had discovered the major
hallmarks of aging and these are things
like mitochondrial dysfunction of energy
decline stem cell depletion telomere
shortening
there's a group of them and we were
quite happy for those years but I've
always been fascinated in trying to find
what's causing all of those because they
don't just happen there has to be in my
view a unifying reason and that's what I
think that I've come up with this is my
best explanation and in the book I
described much of the evidence that
we've accumulated over 10 years so what
I think is causing all of those various
hallmarks is a loss of information the
analog information in ourselves now what
that means is that instead of having
five 10 20 different medicines to tackle
each one of the whole blocks of Aging
if I'm right a single medicine could
reverse the aging process and what is
the sort of physical way in which this
operates what what is it specifically
that is the process that you would be
looking to either undo stop or or or
actually reverse yeah well only in the
last few years we've realised that
across all mammals of course including
ourselves there's what's called the DNA
methylation clock we also call it the
horvath clock named after my friend
Steve Horvath and if I took your blood I
could read how old you are and even
predict when you're going to die and
these marks are part of the epigenome
now we all know the epigenome very well
but the epigenome is the layer above
that that regulates which genes are
turned on and off the epigenome is what
allows us to be to go from a fertilized
cell to a newborn of twenty six billion
cells each one of each tissue with
thousands of different types of cells in
there the epigenome I think is what goes
awry as we get older we lose the
epigenetic information and that's the
analog information of the cell now
anyone who's had a record player or a
cassette tape knows that analog
information is pretty useless at
preserving information and that I think
that's also true for our bodies now the
question is can you find a backup copy
of that epigenetic information
to perform a reset of the cells and I
think we've were coming very close to
being able to do that and we've already
got some some pretty interesting results
in mice already what's the mechanism
through which that could be done is it
the delivery mechanism I'm talking about
are we talking about a pill are we
talking about nanotechnology etc yeah
well it's early days in fact some of
this work is not even published yet
people listeners can find this online
we've posted it it's under peer-review
there have been others who have
published work that shows that you can
also reset the clock so how do we
currently do it well the first way it
was done was to genetically modified
mice that's obviously not going to help
and that was also toxic the way it
worked out we've now packaged a set of
three reprogramming genes that actually
we use what are called Yamanaka factors
Yamanaka genes Yamanaka won the Nobel
Prize in 2012 for learning how to make
stem cells out of skin cells and other
adult cells in the body but we use them
to reset the clock in the body we don't
make stem cells we push them partially
back to where they came from
we deliver them as you said in a virus
right now it's a viral therapy it would
be used we think in the eye initially
which is where the a lot of gene therapy
is being applied in a clinic right now
to correct genetic diseases so we
wouldn't be correcting genetic diseases
necessarily we'd be using it to rewind
the clock and allow tissues and organs
like the AI to recover and become more
youthful and in mice at least we've
managed to restore eyesight in old mice
what's the timeline that understanding
that it's still very early that you
think this may be developed on and
available on uh well I'm an entrepreneur
many people who know me know that very
well I've started many companies over
the years there's a new company that I'm
working with with Horvath a friend I
mentioned a professor at UCLA and myself
and professor Belmonte who did the
initial discovery that I'd mentioned
about
reprograming we've come together to to
make a go at this we're going to be
hopefully treating the first patient in
less than two years from now and our
goal is to treat glaucoma damage to the
eye due to pressure and we think that
that'll be if it works the first of many
treatments of turning back the clock in
various parts of the body and hopefully
eventually throughout the entire body to
have an age reset there are certain
populations that have been studied for
their longevity so there are the ik
Aryans there are you know a number of
these different populations that that
folks have heard of that live longer on
average than others can you talk a
little bit about whether in the work
that you do there is significance to
that my understanding is that much of
their longevity is attributed to
lifestyle it seems as though your work
is operating on a sort of different
level so do those populations have any
research value to you or are we really
dealing with something very very
different no actually it all ties
together you know if my theory didn't
explain the last hundred years of
observation and it wouldn't be a useful
theory so what we what we see and also
predict but we currently see is that a
stable epigenome the ability to slow
down that biological hook does happen
when societies and individuals have
those healthy lifestyles being hungry
every day or every other day
doing a lot of exercise keeping active
keeping the body in a state of high
alert these are the things that slow
down that epigenetic clock that I
believe is a driver if not the main
cause of aging itself now there are also
genes that we are either born of gene
variants that well we're born with if
we're lucky that predisposed to living
over a hundred physical centenarian
families and the variants in those
families are part of this epigenetic
regulatory network some of them are that
we work on a cold sirtuins and the eye
in that so
- and name stands for information
they're silent information regulators
and those are key players in this
epigenetic clock and we can use various
things in our lives such as what we eat
when we eat and how much exercise we do
among other things I put in my book to
slow down that rate of epigenetic clock
ticking there are many others that I
talk about in my book and other things
that can be done but we think these are
central regulators that are found
throughout life and have been with us
since the beginning of life do you have
a particular diet and/or supplement
regimen that you adhere to and the
reason I ask that is a lot of the folks
that work in the field that you work in
seem to have one which sometimes is not
obviously directly related to the
research that the person seems to be
doing so it's more of a curiosity
well yeah Matt mine's more than the
curiosity the work that we do in my lab
can be translated into my family's
lifestyle and what we take of course I
don't recommend to my family that they
take it but they're all scientists and
they know what the what the data said
suggests and the risks far far less than
the potential reward and so the first
discovery that we made was that these
sirtuin regulators of the epigenome need
a molecule called nad and so that was
back in actually in 2002 2003 so I take
nad boosting molecules that I I'm hoping
and the evidence suggests will put my
body in a state of high alert as though
I've been hungrier and in exercising the
right otherwise I don't have time before
I resveratrol this was in the news back
in 2003 we discovered that resveratrol
activates the sirtuin enzyme which is a
protector of the the body and also a
stabilizer of the epigenetic clock and
so resveratrol from Redwine I've been
taking that so as my father for over a
decade now
we both have very good health and so far
so good I should say by the way because
I'm a professor at Harvard Medical
School I know that this is not a
clinical trial it's not work that I'm
going to publish but I also know that
that we've all been born probably a
generation or two to early to know for
sure if these things work to extend
healthy lifespan and so we do have to be
ahead of the curve if we're going to
learn what these molecules are actually
doing that said all of these molecules
have been backed up by clinical trials
that I'm also running typically here at
Harvard and also around the world and we
know safety before any molecules are put
into my body um the last one we studied
was MIT form and we worked with Rafael
de Cobo at NIH to show that mice that
had metformin which is a diabetes drug a
reasonably safe one taken by millions of
people around the world that was
ostensibly extended their lifespan
certainly kept them healthier in human
studies it looks like in tens of
thousands of patients that have been
studied metformin slows down the aging
process prevents cancer heart disease
protein of course diabetes and for that
reason I take triple combo of those
things very interesting stuff and I
highly recommend that folks in the
audience pick up the book life span why
we age and why we don't have to we've
been speaking with the book's author
David Sinclair who's a professor of
genetics at Harvard Medical School
David really interesting having you on
and I so appreciate your time thanks
David I appreciate it too